in your book uh which we've got here and
you say it's all about
restoring the primacy of truth and
rebuilding trust
in the post-trump era so why do you
think there is this problem
with trust and even truth in politics
and how do you fix it
well the greatest fear of the founders
of the united states
was that a demagogue would take the
presidency
and use the power of lies and lies work
there are tens of millions of good
ordinary people in the united states
who believe lies they've been told about
the virus about the election
about our institutions they believe it
because they've been told these lies
over and over and over again by the
president of the united states and his
echo chambers and his enablers
and so the reason it's important to talk
about truth
is to try to not accept that and to push
back against that and look to find a way
to lure those millions of people out of
that fog of lies that's one of the
central challenges
for this next president that's why i
think we have to talk about it
donald trump aimed not just to lie to
people
but really to destroy the notion the
truth exists that we can't know things
and we have to reject that and speak
about it constantly if we're going to be
a healthy country
it's very difficult though isn't it
because you know you say about the
importance of
reinstating truth in the face of lies
but you know in the us you've got lots
of people who think donald trump has
lied
you've also of course got 74 million
people who voted for him at the last
election
more than voted for him back in 2016
they certainly don't think he's a liar
how do you go about restoring this the
truth
and the trust as you say when it's so
polarized people can't even agree on
facts
well i think in a couple ways first is
accidental and tragic
this attack on the united states capital
i think is a needed and i wish it
weren't needed it hadn't happened but a
civics lesson for the american people to
get them to lift their eyes a bit above
the political scrum that they're
normally
focused on and focus on the values that
they connect us and
unite us and i'm optimistic that that's
already happening in the united states
but the mission for the next president
for joe biden has got to be
through the demonstration of competent
honest empathetic leadership
to slowly move those people and i keep
saying slowly because
you can't shout at people who are
trapped in a fog of lies
i've prosecuted cases against fraudsters
where the fraudster pleads
guilty and his victims still come to his
sentencing to speak up for him often the
very last people to acknowledge a fraud
are those who are the victims of it so
it's a slow process but the next
president has to
slowly turn them away from that by
showing them
what leadership really looks like and
that means telling them the truth
being transparent with them and
consistent with them
and showing them the empathy that's been
so lacking the last four years
that's not going to fix america
overnight but that will move
literally millions of people out of the
fog and get us to a healthier place
the very beginning of your when you
first answer you were saying about the
fear of a demagogue
taking over i mean you probably chose
that word quite carefully do you feel
like
donald trump acted like a democrat oh
he's a
absolute the dictionary definition of a
demagogue
a populist demagogue willing to say
anything at any moment
to try to whip people up to support him
and it's been extraordinary the press to
its great credit has tried to keep track
of his lies
and communicate about them but lying
works it's the reason a demagogue
was the great fear of the designers of
the american republic
lying works and we can't ever kid
ourselves that it's ineffective it's
effective
and that's why all of us have to fight
back against it
you mentioned the scenes that we've all
seen of course of those people storming
the capital building
but you've also said that donald trump
supporters are in your words victims
how do you think america should deal
with the people who
did storm the capital what should happen
very differently and i don't mean to
include
i'm talking about other people you know
i have relatives in iowa
who voted for donald trump they're not
people looking to storm the capital and
they're horrified by it
but they are some of them trapped in
that fog of lies different crowd at the
capitol
that crowd at the capitol is a crowd of
criminals and so they have to be dealt
with swiftly and severely to send a
message
that we're just not going to stand for
this that there's a rule of law in the
united states and it has to be brought
to bear
we've long had a radioactive stew in the
united states
of racist misogynist conspiracy-minded
violence
it's been part of america since the
beginning we've controlled it for
generations
by putting it in a containment building
of law and pushing control rods that are
cultural down into that radioaction
radioactivity and control that donald
trump has lifted the control rods and
undermine the integrity of the building
and you saw a a radioactive spill on
capitol hill
we have to rebuild the building push the
rods down in and get that
that awfulness back into the corner of
american life don't kid yourself that it
goes away because it doesn't go away in
america
but it gets pushed back into that
building that's the second mission in
addition to trying to get
those caught in the fog those
non-violent people who are not you're
not worried about them committing crimes
they're just been defrauded moving them
away
you have to question how the attack on
the capital was allowed
to happen when it looked like it'd been
planned on the internet almost in plain
sight i mean
that sounds like a pretty big failure by
police and by
law enforcement doesn't it yep seems
that way to me watching it i was
as an american as a human being sickened
by what i was watching
but as someone who spent a lot of my
life in law enforcement i was angered
by the apparent failure to defend a hill
it sits on a hill with 2 000 officers
assigned to it on a daily basis the
failure to
defend the hill it just mystifies me and
angers me
it's going to be important for our
country to understand that failure
9 11 we were told was a failure of
imagination
we didn't anticipate the way the
terrorists might come at us
this didn't require imagination as you
said this was all over the internet
and the group literally walked slowly
down pennsylvania avenue towards the
capitol
so it was just a failure and we need to
know why at all levels
so that we don't let it happen again how
worried are you that we might see more
violence
in the coming days and weeks
particularly of course around the
inauguration
i'm worried because there are
armed disturbed people
who are in this state of mind where they
believe that their country is being
taken from them and so it's a threat
law enforcement in the states has to
take very seriously
at the same time i know that we have the
capability investigative and
and the tactical capability on scene to
protect these locations
and so i'm optimistic that the threat
will be
neutralized but it has to be taken very
very seriously
you obviously a strong critic of donald
trump he's only got a few more days
in office but would you like to see him
impeached i would
i think there has to be historic
sanction for this behavior it's a close
question as to whether he should be
prosecuted after he leaves office i am
actually of the view that the country
would be better off
if we didn't give him the platform that
a prosecution would for the next three
years
instead turn off the camera lights but
that reasonable people can see that
differently
i don't think anybody can disagree there
has to be a there has to be the letter i
tattooed on him again and ideally i'd
like to see him convicted by our u.s
senate and
barred from ever holding public office
again it's interesting you say that you
don't think it would be the right thing
to
prosecute him you say that in the book
as well it isn't the time for donald
trump to face a criminal investigation
no matter how powerful the evidence you
know i've got to ask you if your book is
all about saving justice the importance
of
applying the law fairly without
discrimination
if there's powerful evidence why don't
you think he should face prosecution
yeah that's that's what makes it such a
hard question and as i say in the book i
could be wrong
it's even a closer question today i say
that simply because as
as important as the principles are that
you enumerated in your question
the country needs to find a way
to heal itself and the new president
needs the opportunity to lead and to
heal us as i said both
literally and spiritually and that'll be
much much harder if the donald trump
show
is on our television screens every
single day in the nation's capital which
is where it would have to be prosecuted
in united states versus donald trump
that he would see that as a show it's
probably what he would want the most
that'll go on for three or four years
how does joe biden
do what our country needs him to do in
that environment
so i'd rather he'd be impeached
convicted barred from office
pursued as they should by local
prosecutors up in new york for the
fraudster he was
before he took office but then i'd like
to see some of the lights go out and he
can stand on the front lawn of
mar-a-lago and shouted cars in his
bathrobe
and none of us will hear it that's the
probably the best thing for the country
very similar to the way we thought about
richard nixon
almost 50 years ago people were angry
that we didn't prosecute richard nixon
but in hindsight it was the wisest
decision for the country and i think
this one's even closer that it's likely
to be the thing that our posterity
sees as a wise decision it's interesting
to hear you say that
the thing that he would like the most is
for the donald trump show to continue
because i am quite fascinated by his
character you of course
know him you've been one-on-one with him
before
what's he like and how do you think he's
going to cope with
not being in office anymore he is a
this sounds like hyperbole i don't mean
it that way there's an absolute
statement of fact
i have never seen an adult with a
greater hunger for affirmation than
donald trump
seen it in two-year-olds and
three-year-olds
affirmation is like air he needs it
constantly
which is what makes the next seven days
or so so dangerous in the states because
he feels the affirmation slipping away
and no doubt feels betrayal by those
around him and so it's striking to
encounter a human being
especially in a leadership role with
that hunger then there's one other piece
that people don't often see
there's a menace to him in private that
you don't pick up
in public but i have felt it sitting
close to him
that that it constantly reminded me of a
mob boss because i've known my bosses
and helped put them in jail
and that menace coupled with that hunger
for affirmation
is a really dangerous recipe i want to
look forward a bit
uh joe biden of course the incoming
president there's a lot of speculation
in the uk about how he'll see us
particularly
you know post-brexit and how do you
think the new president will
form his relationship with the united
kingdom oh i think because
of the nature of the leader he is and
his experience in government he knows
how important that relationship is
in all kinds of ways the one i know best
the security relationship
is essential to the security of the
united states our work with your
intelligence law enforcement and
military folks
is a bedrock of the relationship and
like i said it's not about altruism it's
essential to the security of the united
states you
your colleagues your fellow citizens
save american lives on a regular basis
he knows that
because he's he's been in the white
house situation room and seen the help
that we get from the british security
organizations so i i also think
he's someone who embodies values that i
used to think the republican party stood
for
that alliances the western alliances are
at the center of the piece the world has
experienced in the maine since world war
ii
i think he gets that as well given that
he's an old hand both
in the legislature and in the executive
branch and so i would expect him to
foster a relationship
do you think he'll get on with boris
johnson i don't know i don't know boris
johnson
well enough to know i gather he's a at
least he's portrayed in the states
as a little less crazy a little less
mean donald trump but i don't know
whether that's true or not um thank you
um very much for uh being on the program
with us it's been really fascinating to
talk
and particularly with such a huge events
happening in the united states so thank
you
same here thanks for having me